[Music]
hello
thank you everyone so I'm gonna try and
give you a really quick overview this
should take about 15 minutes so I will
be cutting into your coffee break a bit
I will not be offended if you choose to
get up and leave
so I want to say yeah it's gonna be
really high level overview really feel
free to talk to me or any of the
speakers offline afterwards if you have
questions and I also just want to note
that I stole some of the speaker's
slides for bits and parts of this
presentation so yeah so we had sort of
two parts of this technical talks in the
workshop there the theory ones and the
human-in-the-loop approaches so I
grouped these two together because
they're both about in some sense what I
call super human feedback and I'm gonna
go ahead and try and explain to you what
that means so I'll tell you about
Amanda's talk on iterate identification
and debate first so these are two
different proposals that I both consider
to fall under this framework of super
human feedback and the claim the
motivating claim for this line of work
is that human feedback is not scalable
so a single unaided human just isn't
able to evaluate something as complex as
a complete specification and design of a
transit system for a large city and you
can think of even more extreme examples
like that so for instance well I'll skip
the for instance in the issue of time
and so what are we going to do if we
want to build AI systems that understand
our values and our preferences about
these really complex things when we
can't even give them feedback on on our
preferences in a easier direct way and I
think the answer is maybe somewhat
obvious in in hindsight is that we can
try and get superhuman feedback by using
a is as helpers in the evaluation and
you can also you know think about using
other humans as helpers which is
something that we do all the time right
now but if we want to really leverage AI
as much as possible we're going to want
to use a is to help inform our
decision-making and in particular the
decision-making that we make about the
kind of feedback we give to AI systems
when we're training them and telling
them what kind of behavior we want them
to
if on so there are two examples that
Amanda mentioned in her talk
the first is debate and the other is
amplification these are both recent
papers from last year by the open ai ai
safety team and they're kind of finally
elaborating some ideas that have been
floating around and generating a lot of
excitement I would say in the safety
community for several years so I'll give
you a really short description of what
these are about
debate basically says I'm gonna have my
a I systems hold a debate and then I'm
going to look at the arguments they make
and see which ones I find compelling or
convincing and so that means that I
don't need to figure out what the
crucial considerations are for
evaluating how good a proposed traffic
system are by myself
the AIS will find those out and use them
as weapons against each other in the
debate probably shouldn't say weapons
but arguments is a more accurate word
and so they're going to do all of the
work of figuring out what is actually
important for deciding this question and
then I can just make the judgment based
on their informative arguments
amplification is putting a little bit
more of the work on the human because
this is asking the human to figure out
sort of what the important questions are
and decompose the question into these
subproblems
but then the AIS will figure out how to
answer those problems and provide the
relevant information to the human so
going back to this example of a traffic
system the human might ask so what
actually is it that makes a traffic
system better than another I have some
ideas there are things like how cheap is
it how safe is it are there any
externalities and then you might even
ask the AI systems what are the things
that I'm not thinking about that are
important for evaluating how good a
traffic system is so you find here AI
helpers you ask them all these questions
if they are good at answering such
questions then you will have a lot of
the information that you need in order
to make an informed judgment and you
will be able to make much more broad
judgments than you would be able to by
yourself without the help of these AIS
and the hope is that this will allow us
to scale our training methods to things
that are really vastly beyond keeping
human capabilities because we'll be able
to evaluate them with the help of these
ai's so young like I gave a talk
outlining a research agenda that was put
out by deep mind a couple months ago and
this is sort of in a similar flavor
it starts with what is called reward
modeling so reward modeling is this idea
is let me just say that the goal of this
research agenda is to solve all of the
specification problems that we see which
is basically all the problems about how
do we tell the AI what we want it to do
and that isn't all of the safety
problems but it's a it's a really big
and important chunk of them so it's a
very ambitious agenda so the question is
how are we going to do this and the
answer that Yan has is let's just encode
our tasks in reward functions so reward
functions are usually what we use in
reinforcement learning to tell our
agents what we want them to do the
problem is that for a lot of complex
real world tasks or even ones that might
seem simple to us like do the dishes and
don't do everything anything else like
take over the world might be kind of
hard to write down a reward function for
and the proposed solution is just to
learn a reward function based on human
feedback and then you would use that
learned reward function what we called a
reward model in this picture here to
train the agent so it would be trying to
optimize its reward according to that
reward model now just like I described
before with amplification where the
human can break down a problem and have
the AI help by answering the subproblems
you can do a similar thing using reward
modeling and we call this recursive
reward modeling now there are another
contribution of this paper is that we
point out a number of challenges that
this approach might have and we also
talked about how we might address them
but I'm just going to talk about one
challenge that I think is one of the
most important right now which is this
reward hacking challenge so because the
learned reward model is just a model and
is not exactly the correct reward that
we're actually hoping to optimize there
might be places where these models give
very different numbers and since the
agent that we're training is optimizing
for the learned reward models impression
of what the reward is that can lead to
undesirable outcomes as you see here
where the red which is the learned
reward model the reward assigned by that
model is really high but at the same
time the real reward which is the blue
curve is really low
and we're able to do these experiments
in video games where we know what the
real reward is but in the real world we
might not even have access to that
ground truth reward and have a good way
of detecting it but we do propose that
humans should be evaluating and
monitoring the behavior of the AI so
that they can notice when something like
this happens
so neck
moving on I'll tell you about Dylan's
talk on cooperative inverse
reinforcement learning or Cyril so Cyril
is a paper from 2016 and it's been
around for a while and generated a lot
of interest in the a safety community as
well for a good reason I think and so
one of the things that Dylan wanted to
talk about in this talk is sort of what
is Cyril actually about because I think
there was a lot of misunderstanding
about what the point of Cyril is or how
it's supposed to be used or what it's
really telling us on and there's this
analogy with traditional reinforcement
learning and Cyril and traditional
reinforcement learning can be thought of
as a definition for what it means for an
AI system to be rational and in more
concretely reinforcement learning says a
system is rational if it obeys the
expected utility hypothesis and there's
a lot of work in like economics and
literature going back you know 50 plus
years that sort of gives reasons to
believe that that's a good definition of
rationality now Cyril says what we don't
what we care about is not actually the
rationality of the AI system by itself
we care about the joint rationality of
the AI and human combined system and
those are the kinds of systems that we
really should be analyzing because when
we're training in AI there's always a
human in the loop providing the feedback
about what we want from the system so in
particular
Cyril says that the human and the robot
are going to work together to optimize
the humans reward function but only the
human knows what that is so that means
that the robot has to both try and do
things that are good according to that
reward function but also needs to be
trying to learn more about what the
human actually wants while it's behaving
um there's also a lot of other sort of
insights that and and perspectives that
Dylan shared with us so one of the most
interesting I think is this idea of
viewing machine learning as programming
via incentive and the idea there is that
we have made so much progress in machine
learning largely because we figured out
that we should that it's very effective
to get the behavior you want by
providing incentives as we do in
reinforcement learning and arguably
that's because that tells us that the
agent should behave rationally and rules
out a large class of behaviors that just
don't make sense like flailing around
which doesn't accomplish any goal or any
you know reasonable goal except
answering so anyways I'll move on but I
thought
was really interesting and I really
encourage you to talk to Dylan about his
perspectives on this
yeah next we had eric drexler talking
about the comprehensive AI services
framework so this is another thing
that's kind of been floating around for
a while but eric has finally provided us
with a 200 plus page write-up on it
which I also encourage you guys to look
at I think this is a really important
idea to know about because it really
challenges a lot of the assumptions that
people are often using even implicitly
within the AI safety community and so a
lot of what Eric is hoping to accomplish
here I think is just to get us to change
the way that we're thinking about AGI
and I'll just sort of go through a few
of the most salient points of that for
me so one thing is that if you look at
what people actually want in the real
world out of AI systems the claim that
Eric makes is that people just want
services they want like any other
machine they want something that
accomplishes some task for them and that
really doesn't need to be an agent and
arguably it shouldn't even be an agent
or certainly not one that has these
really long term goals that lead it to
try and shape the entire future and
acquire all sorts of resources really
what we want are AI services and those
are going to be performing tasks that
are resource bounded and time bounded so
really we sort of know what we want and
that's to do this thing and then have
the AI system be done and shut off and
sort of a wait for their instructions
another point that he makes is that when
we talk about VA I this can be a very
give us a very misleading picture of
what AI systems are actually going to
look like in practice and do look like
because systems that we build are
usually modular and have a lot of
different components that are doing
different subtasks and that's just a
very different picture from having a
single unified agent with a long-term
goal finally Eric claims that this is
comprehensive or at least the vision for
this framework which again it's just a
framework in a way of thinking about
things not a technical blueprint that we
can go out and implement right away is
for this to be comprehensive so anything
that you wanted to do with an AGI system
Eric says you can do with comprehensive
AI services and I think that's a really
important idea to engage with and I just
wanted to note that this is still not
considered a complete solution for
safety it's really more of a way of
approaching the safety problems I'm
gonna skip this one for now so now we
have
the theoretical talks as I as I said so
Scot garabrant I was here to tell us
about embedded agency so Scot and
Abraham recently wrote a series of posts
blog posts for Miri that talked about
this that are really excellent I think
if you have heard of Miri and think
they're interesting but don't really
know what their research is supposed to
be about or why they are interested in
these problems this is what you should
read this is really the best explanation
I've seen for the motivation for their
work so the the underlying issue that
Scott is pointing out is that
reinforcement learning which is how we
often think what we often think of as a
definition for AI is actually a leaky
abstraction it says that the agent and
the environment lived in these sort of
separate worlds and they only
communicate via a well-defined interface
that we get to specify as the designers
now in the real world that's not that's
not a good description of physical
reality because the AI system and its
environment are really all just part of
physical reality and that leads to a
bunch of really interesting deep
technical and even pseudo philosophical
questions that really break the ways
that we're used to thinking about agency
and thinking about artificial
intelligence within the reinforcement
learning framework so in particular
they're grouped into these four
categories and I guess I talked about
not having well-defined input output
channels let me just give an example of
what what sort of thing we're talking
about by that when I look at the code of
my reinforcement learning agent and I
make a decision about what I'm going to
do based on that code for instance I'm
going to shut down the agent or I'm
going to make another agent like it but
changing something about the design that
agents code has just impacted its
environment which I'm a part of in a way
that totally circumvents its actions so
it wasn't an action taken by this code
that made me choose to do these things
it was me looking directly at the code
of the agent and in reinforcement
learning we typically totally abstract
that away and pretend that the code is
just not a part of the real world so
here's just a diagram that sort of shows
how all of these different things that
Mary have been talking about can sort of
be viewed as part of this general
problem and in terms of those categories
I gave you so next we had to talk by
Becca about measuring side effects so
side effects are basically disruptions
to the environment that aren't necessary
for
Publishing an agent's tasks so an
example is like if you're moving a box
you don't need to break a vase that's in
your way usually to get the box where it
needs to go you can step around the vase
on the other hand you need to break some
eggs to make an omelet so that shouldn't
really be considered a side effect even
though it's disrupting the environment
it's necessary for accomplishing the
task so one of the contributions because
work here is to lay out some desiderata
that we want for any measurement of side
effects and this is really interesting
because we don't really know how to
formalize what we mean by side effects
and I think any progress on what that
would look like is really worth paying
attention to
in particular I wanna I want to
highlight this last desiderata which is
the offsetting incentive and so the idea
here is that if you just do some naive
way of telling the eye not to have side
effects it's actually going to try and
correct for things that happen because
it accomplished its task even if the
it's not correcting for things that were
necessary for accomplishing the task so
the example here is like the air reasons
well you know if I hadn't touched your
notebook from outside then it would have
gotten wet when it rained so I need to
make sure that your notebook gets wet so
that I didn't have this side effect of
making your notebook dry instead of wet
and that's something that we don't want
right on so just briefly I'll say Vika
defined this relative reach ability
criterion which basically satisfies all
of these desiderata if you set it up
correctly although there are still a lot
of challenges in terms of making this
practical in terms of how to compute it
and so on I'll move on so we had Raman
are talking about verification security
and containment so one thing that people
think about when they think about AI
safety is let's just put the AI in a box
and make sure it doesn't get out that
seems safe and a lot of people within
the safety community I think have sort
of poo pooed this idea and said that you
know that's not gonna work the AI is
going to break out of the box but at the
same time I think everyone agrees that
it's kind of worth having as an option
for a fallback or maybe just for while
we're doing experiments for things that
we don't really think are dangerous but
might be and so there's this goal of
making a box that's really good and that
actually will contain an AI assuming
that the AI doesn't find some really
clever way to hack out of the
and of course the problem with doing
this in a straightforward way is that
the AI if it is like redoing
consequentialist reasoning like
reinforcement learning agent would have
some incentives to try and get out of
the box and there's a proposal by Stuart
Armstrong that sort of tries to fix
these incentives and does someone a good
job of that and so what Ramana did in
this in this work that he presented is
he actually verified these parts of the
design that Stuart says are going to
make the box safer and in general ROM
honest talk was about the potential to
use these verification technologies in
machine learning and for safety purposes
which I think really hasn't been talked
about or explored that much but it is
really important area and this can both
prevent like obvious bugs in the
implementation that AI could use to sort
of to break out or to do things that we
don't intend it to do like maybe you
guys have seen this example with a Mario
playing AI that can exploit some bug in
the code of the video game to just jump
immediately to the final level but it's
also something that has a lot more
potential going forward I think if we
can figure out how to specify the sort
of things that we want to be verified so
there has been a bit of work on that so
far in terms of specifying and sorry
verifying adversarial robustness which
is fairly easy to specify when you are
only thinking about these very limited
kinds of adversarial examples which are
like norm balls around the inputs more
generally though it seems like we do
have a big issue with applying these
techniques more broadly in terms of
specifying what we actually want to
verify but I think it's really
interesting Avenue to be exploring as
well so finally after all the talks we
had a debate which I moderated between
Ana Solomon and Peter Eckersley and the
topic was basically will future AG AI
systems be optimizing a single long term
goal so is Eric wrong and we're actually
going to end up with you know these
super agent T super intelligent long
term optimizers whether we like it or
not and so we tried to make that more
specific by saying even if we sort of
all agree that that's a bad thing are
there reasons it might happen anyways
and just to give you a really quick
highlight of debate two reasons that
were proposed of why that might happen
any
anyways have to do with what are called
inner optimizers and then finally there
might be economic incentives for these
kinds of agents arguably because they
might be more efficient at doing
something like I've never been told to
take my time doing something like
maximizing profit on the stock market
that's something that's very easily
encoded as a reinforcement learning
objective and then Peter Eckersley also
mentioned this idea that having a
preference for respecting other agents
autonomy might actually be a way that
you can do something that is meaningful
II different from optimization of a
utility function as we usually think of
it and that's really it for my talk so
thank you all for your attention and
talk to me afterwards if you want to
know more
[Applause]
[Music]